being signed to eminem
it's got to be a gift and a curse how
how would you kind of perceive it
because we always hear like
what curse what do you think is a curse
i mean eminem is you know he's he's uh
the greatest rapper alive that is
what i mean so like when people think of
eminem they think of him being like the
goat you know and
i feel like any time he signs an artist
it's very much expected that that artist
also has to be in that and like think
about he signed you he signed
the griselda guys slaughterhouse back in
the day i'm forgetting i'm sure
some other artists who else is on shady
yellow wolf
who yellow wolf yep oh yellow wolf yeah
but that means he's not on shady anymore
no i don't know who's on shady you don't
know that i don't know it kind of
falling out oh my bad i believe [ __ ]
yellow
no i don't say that my bad i don't know
royce my dog but let me just tell you
like this i don't think royce is on
shady though but he was at a point come
on man wasn't he i thought they were
just freaking out that means evil i
don't think that racism hey you know
better than me
why you thought
is really one of my favorite people in
the world he's also one of the greatest
rappers of all time literally i
literally think at any given time he's
he might be the greatest rapper alive
there's like a few of those guys it's
like royce
black thought uh
i think conway's in that discussion i
think when you're at your peak you could
be in that discussion
eminem if you didn't say something
towards me i was about to trip like not
[ __ ] you not just beside me for a reason
but what i'll be saying is like i don't
know i never feel it because
it's it's for one i'm competitive so
it's like everybody's like even playing
field for me obviously i respect
everything how eminem changed my life
but you know what i'm saying i'm still
trying to get to where i'm trying to go
so i don't feel no pressure from
whatever eminem has accomplished because
i like got my own goals and also it's
like the [ __ ] i face in my neighborhood
it's like once i come to this [ __ ] it's
like there's nothing it's like whatever
with some little you know it's a little
not like that's little white kids on the
internet don't be mad i'm not rapping
fast it's the most
the most that's a thing it is a thing
for real for real my i it's like from
the outside looking in a lot of people
think i don't fit what the shady roster
stands for you know what i'm saying
eminem know you know i could borrow at
any given time and that's not i just
don't want to do it all the time you say
you can bar up eminem at any given time
or you know what i'm saying maybe but i
was just saying he know i could go off
right right at any given time you're
capable of but that's not giving them
and i'm saying i'm more so in delivering
my message and if great lines come in in
the process of that that's dope little
metaphors and stuff but trying to get my
point across and make great music and
talk to my people so
yeah don't care about what no shady fans
are saying i love the [ __ ] out of y'all
but you know what i'm saying